well it's been a source of massive
controversy all over the world how
exactly did covid19 begin
the theory remains out there that it
began at a wet market or it was somehow
obtained from just an animal in the wild
but the going theory these days it
started off as a quote-unquote fringe
theory and now it's basically well
accepted as the mainstream theories that
this actually began
at the woohen institute of horology
joining us on the line to discuss is
matt ridley he's a best-selling author
his books include genome the rational
optimist and how innovation works his
latest book is viral the search for the
origin of covid 19. matt thanks so much
for joining the show really appreciate
it great to be honest and i've
co-authored this book with alina chan
who's a brilliant young scientist so
let's talk about the timeline here when
it comes to the development of covid 19.
your timeline goes all the way back to
2012. and so i think a lot of people
obviously only became aware of the virus
at the beginning of 2020. uh it was
circulating in china slightly before
that but why does your timeline start in
well because when the virus was
discovered in early 2020 uh it was
immediately noticed by the wuhan
institute of virology that there was a
very similar virus out there 96.2
that was found in the freezer of the
wuhan institute of virology it was
collected in
2013 following an incident in 2012 in a
copper mine
about 1800 kilometers away from wuhan
that's the distance from orlando to new
york so the question is how would a bat
virus from way down in the southwest of
china have got to wuhan that's the
question we have to ask ourselves we now
know that that that virus is not found
in bats around wuhan so something
brought it a long way from a long way
away and we know that the closest virus
came because scientists went there and
collected it and the reason they did so
was because six people got sick in 2012
three of them died this might have been
the first case of a sars-like virus
directly infecting people from a bat and
so it's it's an incident of considerable
interest
so
in 2014 the united states announced a
moratorium on gain of function research
what is gain of function research why do
people even perform gain of function
research i think a lot of people look at
the sort of notion that scientists make
diseases more deadly or or they or they
change the function of the disease and
they freak out because that sounds
something like the stand so what is it
and why is it useful why do scientists
do it in the first place
right there's a there's uh a big
controversy within science between some
people who think this is a very
important useful tool for understanding
the enemy for getting to know viruses
and what threat they might pose
and there's other people who say this is
dangerous this is like looking for a gas
leak with a lighted match and there was
a big controversy about this as you say
in 2014 and there was a moratorium for a
few years on some of these experiments
and why was why do they do it well the
the ostensible reason is that we need to
understand the threats that are out
there that
the millions of viruses that might cause
pandemics and in order to do that we've
got to grow them in laboratories and
study them and it's not easy to grow
them in laboratories so we need to juice
them up a bit so that they can infect
human cells in laboratories so that we
can study them
better so that we've got more samples to
work on that's the kind of rationale for
this and then we've got to work out how
many genetic steps away from
causing a pandemic are they
um how many mutations would it require
that was the most controversial
gain of function experiments in 2014
were about exactly that with influenza
viruses how close were they how easily
could they turn into something that
would threaten mammals as opposed to
birds so they did it they found they
made it infect mammals instead of birds
and you can see the problem here is that
you know
this tech this these techniques
are getting pretty close to doing
dangerous things with viruses and given
the fact that we do get lab leaks all
the time they're fairly frequent all
around the world most of them are not
serious but some of them are very
serious
you know you cannot constrain these
viruses very easily and it's very easy
for people to get infected in labs
particularly if you're working at lower
biosecurity levels
then it is important i think to have a
long hard look at ourselves in science
and i'm a fan of biotechnology i'm not a
critic of it and see whether these
experiments are justified um what counts
as sort of gain and function research
this has become a topic of massive
controversy in the united states given
the the questions over nih funding of
research at the wuhan institute of
virology some people maintain that gain
of function research is apparently just
about making viruses more infectious
within a within a species uh and somehow
this would exempt cross species jumping
from gain to function research that
seems like uh uh almost a
counter-intuitive notion of what gain of
research function is that would be
controversial like it would seem less
controversial to increase the
transmissibility of a virus within a
species than to make it more
transmissible across species
right and this is the kind of
slightly theoretical arguments that we
get into and i'm not here to take sides
in a u.s political debate i'm not not an
american but um
you're right that the one of the
exemptions from the from the moratorium
on gain of function research was to say
if this is an animal virus that cannot
infect humans then go ahead do these
experiments
even if you're making it more infectious
within those uh species um
and
yes fine but then what do you mean about
what do you how does that apply to
taking a virus and
infecting human cells with it is that
training it on the human species making
it easier to infect the human species um
does that count well it probably does
those experiments were done but not
necessarily in the u.s during the
exemption and then there was another
exemption for experiments that were
already underway um and so on so there
were plenty of loopholes
in the moratorium that enable the nih to
say well yes some of these experiments
did continue but they weren't
necessarily out with the the legislation
and the the moratorium ended in 2017 and
from then on they said we'll allow
gainer function experiments if a
committee decides they're okay so it's
very much a sort of judgmental thing
we'll get some more with matt ridley in
just one second first this holiday
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors are the best deals of the year on
the award-winning ring alarm i'm sure
you all know about the ring video
doorbell by now but did you know that
ring makes an award-winning alarm as
well ring alarm is a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself so whether
you're busy running across town or
across the country this season you and
your loved ones can rest easy knowing
your home is protected it's more than
just security ring alarm protects your
home from flood freeze and fire as well
plus it's a lot cheaper than the other
companies for what they charge for a
month you get an entire year of ring
alarm with professional monitoring right
now for the best deals of the year on
ring alarm go to ring.com forward slash
ben i use ring to keep track of my kids
and frankly i have three kids they're
running all over the place and sometimes
you look around oh where'd the kid go
well that's when it's a great time to
pull up that ring app and see where for
example your five-year-old son went and
is he setting something on fire so this
holiday season deck the halls walls
doors and windows with the best deals of
the year on the award-winning ring alarm
head on over to ring.com forward slash
ben get a great deal on a ring alarm
security kit today that's ring.com
forward slash man you'll be keeping your
family safe it is a great device it's
easy to install and it's not going to
cost you a fortune ring.com forward
slash ben so we fast forward now to 2018
and it's pretty clear at this point
according to your timeline the wuhan
institute of virology is is doing
tremendous numbers of experiments on on
bats and bad viruses they even file for
patents on bat breeding cages so what so
there's a lot of smoke here as far as if
you're looking for sort of smoke as to
where this virus was developed
this seems like the timeline so where
what sort of smoke are we are we seeing
at this point right well um by 2018
we now know and largely thanks to leaks
and freedom of information requests we
now know that wuhan institute virology
which is the leading institute for
studying bat born stars like
coronaviruses in the world by a mile you
know it's got more samples of these it's
doing more experiments than these it's
publishing more results on these viruses
we now know that they were they had done
experiments that increased the
infectivity of these viruses by swapping
parts of the spike gene with other parts
we know that in 2018 they were
collecting viruses not just from
southern china but also from laos
cambodia and other neighboring countries
bringing them back to wuhan we know they
were sequencing these viruses and they
had hundreds
of different versions of sars-like
viruses in the lab what we don't know is
what they collected after 2016. the
hundreds we know about were all
collected before 2016. and that's what
we'd really
like to know um and then we found out
only just a couple of months ago that
there was a plan
to put a thing called a fury cleavage
site into the genome of one of these
viruses
with a view to making it slightly more
infectious or very much more infectious
as part of a way of making it easier to
study it now that plan wasn't funded by
the us government by the pentagon to
which the application was made but it
may have been funded by the chinese
government now that's very interesting
because this virus has a fearing
cleavage site in it none of its
relatives do no other size like uh
coronavirus does
and it's an increasingly um large
mystery as to how it got its fearing
cleavage site we don't think in our book
that we know the answer we don't think
we can rule out that it came through a
market route you know through the food
chain but we do think that there is a
huge amount of smoke as you say that
suggests that finding a sars-like
coronavirus outbreak in humans in the
only city with a huge sars-like
coronavirus research program deserves a
certain amount of scrutiny
we're speaking with matt ridley the book
is viral the search for the origin of
covenant 19. so again we only become
familiar in the west uh at least in the
united states with with covet 19 in
january in late january the who is still
maintaining that there is no human human
transmission of coven 19 which of course
ends up not only being untrue but pretty
obviously a lie by the chinese
government promulgated via the the who
as it turns out the first diagnosis of
kobe 19 is happening it now appears back
in november of 2019 so months before the
rest of the world was even notified
about all this and as you note in the
book there's a lot of alarm bells going
off in china about kova 19 especially
among people who are associated with the
uh institute of virology uh by by early
in mid december
that's right um it it's it's the middle
of december when the hospitals start
picking up cases and saying hang on
there's something happening here and
it's pretty obvious from some of these
early cases that it's not they're not
all collect catching it from animals
they're some of them are clearly
catching it from each other you know
there's
families coming in who've infected each
other and things like that um
retrospectively we can be pretty sure
that there were cases in november that
there was a leaked document which south
china morning post had which showed a
17th november case but that was
retrospectively diagnosed it wasn't till
mid-december that they start picking it
up and once they start picking it up the
hospital some of the hospital doctors
raise the alarm and say we've got
something that looks awfully like sars
this could be very dangerous and they
get punished for spreading the word i
mean they get reprimanded and shut down
and told to shut up now that is not the
way
to stop a pandemic early in its tracks
to help doctors off for talking about it
um and so you know the real worry is the
degree the possibility that we could
have stopped this pandemic if there had
been a more sensible approach from the
chinese authorities
in december uh whereas in fact as you
say right up until the middle of january
uh the chinese authorities and the world
health organization are saying despite
taiwanese insistent to the
country but taiwan is ignored by the
world health organization because that
china's perhaps despite that um they're
saying that there's no human to human
transmission i mean it really is amazing
i mean you talk about in the book the
fact that the chinese vaccine developer
sino farm is already manufacturing of
acts by the beginning of january
meanwhile they're simultaneously telling
the rest of the world that all is well
there's nothing to really worry about
here and it's only at the very end of
january we start hearing human to human
transmission and it is because of that
timeline delay that we don't shut down
travel it is because of that timeline
delay that a lot of countries in the
west aren't taking this seriously i
remember being on the air when all this
was happening and i was citing the whole
saying well you know the who is saying
there's no human to human transmission
we still have only individual cases
cropping up and and so i think this sort
of 2020 hindsight where it's like all
the politicians knew all the politicians
knew in late january how bad this was
going to be it just seems like that's
that is 2020 hindsight the only people
who absolutely knew how bad it was were
the people inside the chinese government
that's correct i i'm the same i was
taking world health organization um uh
uh
reassurance at first
uh site you know i mean i i i i believed
it uh and you know it was a while before
it became clear that this had uh escaped
and become uh global once it was out in
february
uh and people all over europe and north
america were picking it up there was no
way we were going to stop it with travel
bans probably not with lockdowns either
vaccines were probably going to be the
only way we were really going to get get
on top of it we might slow the spread
with lockdowns but
whereas if we had been completely
apprised of the situation in late
december and had taken the precautionary
approach that this may well be spreading
human to human transmission by human
human transmission then i think it could
have been nipped in the bud and 5 to 15
million people who are now dead would
not be dead so one of the things that
you talk about in the book is also the
the amazing official move uh in in so
many of our scientific journals to shut
down any talk about the possibility of a
lab leak theory at the very beginning of
the pandemic you had people like peter
daschik who were working very hard to
suppress any possibility that people
would be discussing the lab leak origin
story uh there were social media
companies that were suppressing any
stories that were being written about
this sort of stuff maybe can talk a
little bit about why that narrative was
was shut down so early and why it was
seen as such a fringe theory from the
very beginning it is an extraordinary
aspect of the story um neither alina
chan nor i began by thinking that the
lab leak was likely we were seeing
papers from virologists saying it's not
possible it's a conspiracy theory it's a
crackpot idea um
and they were confusing two things one
was the idea that it was a deliberate
release of a bio weapon and the other
was that it was an accidental release of
a virus that was being studied in the
laboratory and that helped to to shut it
down but there was clearly a confluence
of interest here between the chinese
authorities which didn't want the finger
pointed at the in wuhan instead of
virology and western scientists who
didn't want the finger pointed at
science in general um and a lot of
western politicians who were
somehow
you know took the view that it was
highly unlikely it would have come out
of a lab we haven't had pandemics out of
labs before well we haven't been
studying viruses in this depth before is
the answer to that and somehow all this
came together and a really weird piece
of censorship happened
for you know best part of a year whereby
you weren't allowed to discuss the
possibility of a laboratory leak
on various parts of social media science
scientific journals and mainstream media
were very hostile to this it changed in
may 2021 when after a farcical world
health organization investigation uh it
became clear that uh you couldn't rule
out this possibility and by then you
know the the trail had gone cold on the
wet market they tested 80 000 animals in
china and none of them had the virus so
the you know in the case of sars and
mers we knew within two months how
people were getting infected in the
early days
and china had not shared any details of
the early cases still haven't so
it it really it's very surprising to me
as a
you know somebody who believes in
science and open inquiry that that so
much establishment science was so
resistant to being open-minded about
this possibility
and actually that left a vacuum for
people who hate science to come in and
make these points which is one of the
things i regret about this and the book
again is viral the search for the origin
of coven 19 the co-author is matt ridley
so matt you know this is this is one of
those areas where i know you're not
political but you do have to wonder
about the leverage that china was able
to exert throughout this entire process
uh in in preventing number one
information from getting out and number
two manipulating the who and then number
three in in suppressing the narrative
afterward because obviously as you say
there's a confluence of interest to
prevent any dissemination of information
on this people on on you know various
sides of the aisle uh who were sort of
seen as kooks for a year were were
reporting on this as early i remember as
as like april may of 2020 and and this
was seen as completely insane and then
by january you had the u.s state
department that was issuing a fact sheet
possibly questioning whether it was a
lab origin
issue and then by august the
administration's like well maybe we'll
investigate they do their little
investigation they come up with nothing
because it turns out the chinese are
just not transparent it should be i
think frightening to the to the future
of both scientific inquiry and disease
suppression that the chinese government
was able to wield this much power
throughout the process i i agree with
you and i think
you know going back 10 or 20 years china
was a relatively reasonable um player in
the world and you could have a
conversation with it about various
things in the last few years it has
become
extraordinarily propagandistic that the
wolf warrior diplomacy thing has led to
really very naked uh pushing of one line
and you know i mean they they put out a
thing just yesterday saying that i was a
liar um for writing this book
i don't know which you know they won't
of course say which lies um i've told um
uh you know the there's a strong
tendency in the chinese government to
try and propagandize this story and that
doesn't necessarily mean uh that it was
a laboratory leak they also don't
particularly like the idea of it coming
from a wildlife market because that
threatens the traditional chinese
medicine with xi jinping
champions which is why they tried to
accuse other countries of sending it to
china on frozen food which was a sort of
bonkers theory if you thought about it
literally five minutes
so yes there is a problem here and
there's a problem in the west too
because you know we're we're desperate
to get the chinese to sign up to climate
treaties we're desperate to get them to
collaborate on trade and lots of other
issues so we do sometimes
soft pedal issues and you remember
australia put its neck out quite at the
australian government in in the spring
of 2020
said let's have an independent
investigation into the origin of covid19
they didn't say to come out of a lab
they didn't even use that word and yet
for saying that
they were
hit with very severe trade sanctions by
the chinese government that is not the
way
to conduct this kind of thing what we
need is a pandemic treaty where all
countries agree to share any information
that's relevant when a pandemic begins
and if china won't sign that well then
we'll then we'll uh you know
will know their true colors i mean this
i think really is the question is what
do we do for the future here so you
mentioned the possibility of a pandemic
treaty here uh you know it it seems like
this sort of thing could easily repeat
itself i mean we've had several viral
outbreaks over the course of the last 20
years this one obviously by far the most
deadly but you know there's talk about
the possibility that a far more deadly
virus the ifr on this thing turned out
to be a lot lower than originally
thought originally we thought the
infection fatality rate was going to be
three to five percent which would have
meant not five to 15 million people that
it would have been maybe 10 times that
amount uh it turns out that it's much
lower than that but there's no reason to
think that this couldn't happen again so
what sort of steps should we be taking
as the west to protect ourselves
given the fact that there's so much
dishonesty floating in the ether here
yeah well it it it's not an easy
question at all and uh yeah you know i
think one of the things we we have to
it we have to find out how it started
because that's the best way of
preventing it is to know what we're
dealing with you know if it started
through the food chain then we need to
regulate the food chain better if it
started through research then we need to
regulate research better
we need to take a leaf out of the
airline industries book they brought
down um
fatalities
by an enormous percentage almost got rid
of them
through a technique of basically sharing
information basically saying whenever a
plane crashes the whatever
the lessons that will be learned for
that will be shared across the industry
and across the world everybody will be
able to learn from from from what
happens and that was a crucial part of
uh increasing safety in the air i think
we ought to do the same here we ought to
to get people sharing information so
that we can understand what risks we're
running either in the laboratory or in
the food trade or in some other way um
and that feels to me like an urgent
piece of diplomacy i don't see it on the
agenda of the g7 or the g20 or any of
these organizations i think it should be
this is matt ridley his book is viral
the search for the origin of coven 19 it
is a must read
certainly a scary reminder of uh exactly
where we are at this point in time with
regard to world
mobilization against viruses like covet
19 man thanks so much for joining the
show really appreciate it
thank you ben
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed